pounce on you you just lose murder the
cream / / / aunt when the pet dragon
melts your throne
where you gonna sit down these Thrones
apply molten metal you can't sit on that
you bring your phone's big time don't
burn your parts burp bugs are a big time
Bubba don't burn i'm come on zo formerly
employed actor a current how true aren't
you pretty
I'm pretty businessman if you want to
avoid bumper you gotta come by to do
news yawns milk Bruce rocks you can
anytime from Kolkata and they're all
melt fruit we got already not multiple
we got all your nom meltable furniture
needs Thrones
this ain't burning melt toilets melt
chairs feedbacks chaise lounges sounds
the clients pools including barstools
but not limited to bar schools st. and
couches second chair Stevens
loveseat just the field sub it's County
beds Murphy beds suck wombats sleep in a
bed in from town silly things just table
soundfont simple machine
tables including coffee tables signing
table drop leaf tables and tables in
those little tables as you put
tchotchkes on god please be Jackie's
other types melt ona prices that's it
any budget provided that budget with
large man your prices will name a bigger
one
guaranteed car my little Zoe's no proof
throats call now away we don't have a
post come on back
[Applause]